i'm struggling between
two instincts on the mask thing i
increasingly think the mask thing is
uh
diabolical especially as we inflicted on
children and pretend that it's going to
be low cost and that the reason that
we're doing it is about keeping them
safe from something that would actually
render them
perfectly safe indefinitely if they got
it
but
the
other thing is
there's some i think i must have picked
it up from fiction somewhere but there's
some sort of an obligation to
respect a highly capable enemy right to
note what the enemy has done right and
you can imagine being some kind of
warrior on a battlefield and you know
somebody out foxes you and you both
suffer from it but also can appreciate
the elegance of what they've done
the mask thing is diabolical genius
it is absolutely diabolical genius
because of two things one
the symbolic nature of it
right the fact that they have gotten us
to remind each other
of just how dangerous everybody is if
you don't let your guard your literal
guard down right or if you do let your
literal guard down
that is a beautiful metaphor right
everybody else they're your enemy
they're a hazard to you right and the
point is unless you're sitting next to
them in a cafe
well that's the thing as you and i have
begun to joke about the coveted layer
the coveted layer exists up with the
wait staff right because they're
standing and obviously the covet is up
there and it's also very useful to have
them be othered
wonderful to have them be othered
because of the class implication of it
right you are being served there at the
table masked down they are serving mask
up it's lovely the way it it separates
us
um
everything for division
right everything to divide us but then
the
the most amazing part of it to me is
at the point that you begin to realize
that this mask thing that the evidence
that the mask thing actually works by
putting you know putting them on healthy
people that that protects anybody it
does not right what's more mask versus
not mask is not the category most masks
are garbage right this is something i
got wrong okay most masks are garbage
for mass to stand any chance of doing
any good you have to get a really good
one and you have to know how to use it
and that's not what we're being mandated
to do right this is a symbolic gesture
that has got us constantly in the
mindset of covid and it is exactly the
same goddamn thing as at the beginning
of this when they shut down the beaches
and the trails and you and i were saying
hey wait a minute outside is where you
want people to go they are safest out
there it's mentally good for them they
can interact with each other normally
and not be in such terrifying fear all
the time no they should sit inside eat
doritos play on social media and wait
for the vaccine that's effectively what
was being said and so the thing is the
masks um
are the way of getting the constant
reminder out there where it doesn't
belong
right
and it is amazing and the point is as
soon as you realize this and you say you
know what
the masks
really are that's the way the enemy has
intruded into every interaction that we
are going to have and we are obligated
to stand up against it but now you're in
a bind
right
if you don't wear your mask
while others are wearing the mask
you are one of two things
you are either enlightened about the
fact that the masks don't work and in
rebellion
but much more likely you're just not
somebody who cares very much about other
people right you're not even willing to
put on a mask to protect other people
from a disease right and so the point is
that's that's the trap here is that we
can't rebel even those of us who are
enlightened and understand the problem
and frankly even me who was ahead of
this more than almost anybody and
championing masks as a an obvious remedy
at the beginning before we knew that
they didn't work right even i am in this
bind where i can't stand up and say you
know what i'm not wearing the mask
anymore and it's not about the rest of
you it's about the people who are using
this mask mandate to
to separate the rest of us right i can't
make that point because just simply not
wearing a mask broadcasts the message
that i'm inconsiderate of others health
which is not what motivates me at all
and yet part of what is being
demonstrated
is that even
even we will comply with some things
right
so increasingly i think what we need
is a mechanism whereby
if we have to put on a mask we can
indicate that we are not putting it on
out of belief that we are not going to
stigmatize anyone who decides that they
should not wear a mask because we know
the truth of the thing so that we are
not in the position of being induced to
broadcast a false message of
indifference to our fellow man in order
to rebel against some governmental
authority that is abusing its power
and i don't know exactly how we get
there but we need to
we need to do it and we need to do it
right away because because this mask
thing is such genius right they're
getting us it's like they've gotten all
of us to wear their logo broadcasting
their brand everywhere right and to put
our own spin on it and it's enough right
this is this is evil
[Music]